my guest tonight is a comedian actor and
a judge
on america's got talent now he has a new
podcast
howie mandel does stuff please welcome
howie mandel howie thank you for joining
me
on zoom that takes a real comment have i
been welcomed by your audience
yes um they're going crazy right now
they're
going nuts so should we hold for a
second
yeah hold it hold it hold it i'm waiting
for them to sit down
wow you are popular please
sit there they go they're sitting there
thank you
thank you howie i gotta i gotta give it
to you because
um i haven't said this to anyone else
in a year but you
were right when everyone else was wrong
for years for years and years when you
would come on my show
you would do the fist bump not the
handshake you
would wash your hands and you would say
that you were afraid of
germs viruses and everybody kind of
laughed it off you were right
we were wrong howie yeah i bow to you
i think it is latin for told ya yeah um
uh but there's no uh
there's really no sense of vindication i
gotta tell you that this has been
hell yeah and and for me specifically
and
the the comfort that i had with my
discomfort was with my
you know somebody i've been open about
my mental health and i've always
uh you know i am just a small snippet of
the issues that i deal with is is
germaphobia
and uh you know i've dealt with that but
the beauty was that was my nightmare
that every so often i could be snapped
out of
in the real world where people go howie
howie you're not gonna get
howie don't worry howie you can shake
hands how
you can lick this but now that
there's no waking up from that nightmare
you know you're all in my dream
and it's not a dream anymore right so
there's no vindication
i want to be able to go out and say
howie you're overthinking this how
you're over
so this has been a really tough time and
uh i think i was just talking
to your producer before uh you know i'm
in therapy i've been in therapy for
years but i
i think in the last year i've moved my
therapist into a whole new tax bracket
this zoom thing is you know because i
don't have to get in a car and go
anymore i can just
click and zoom so it's like it's like
buying stuff
uh on amazon um you can just click on
your therapist number at any time and
before you know it you've spent hundreds
of thousands of dollars
talking to somebody between the
therapist and amazon
you know between all the protective gear
that i've been able to find
and has been sent to me every soap
company has
sent me a lifetime supply of uh
you know hand sanitizers and soaps yeah
but you must have here's the other thing
i remember thinking about you a year ago
when the when the pandemic was breaking
out and they said there's a ppe
shortage there's a there's a sanitizing
gel
shortage i thought it's howie mandel he
has
all of it you bought all of it years ago
didn't you
didn't you i was hoarding i was hoarding
but
thank god i i spoke to my wife and we
released
it not all at once but as needed as
needed and i think
i think we've done a good job now and
you know what i'm told your prices were
reasonable
you know uh you made you made a little
something but it was reasonable
yeah it's a win-win
[Laughter]
now here okay you you brought this up
you brought up your wife and uh your
lovely wife you've been married for
how many years 41. 41 years but who's
counting 41.
41 years uh and you've told me
many times that the secret to your
marriage
is that you work a lot and you go on the
road
yeah and that made me curious
you've been in quarantine with your wife
for a year
how's the marriage doing well
like the pandemic you know there's uh
we're trying to plat
the thing is that um that's what did
make it work i i realized
you know and now with uh you know the
advent of
uh you know no audiences and no theaters
i'm going crazy being with myself so i
can't imagine what it's like
living with i don't have to imagine she
tells me what it's like living with me
um we had and in the first
three months of lockdown i think about
march april
may in may um uh
what was march i can't remember we
celebrated our 40th anniversary
and i said honey i was trying to be
romantic i said you want to redo our
vows hers
was enough already um that's her
that's her that's her 40-year vow is
enough already
with a sweet what a sweet vow well she's
always been
honesty is her policy and uh the truth
is
when i'm not around people seem to like
me
more than you know it's nice if i appear
on your show for a few minutes or i go
to a concert for an hour and a half
people seem to have fun living with me
is i
i i'm telling you this living with me is
no fun i
spend all day just trying to get away
from me
yeah so i can't imagine how another
human being so i'm hoping at
some point when things are open and free
that i could uh
get her a medal or a trophy she is the
most deserving person
in humanity just for putting up with a
world pandemic
and howie mandel all in the same year at
the same time and even when i do
try humor she'll go was that joke you
know or who was that
and and that's actually you know how the
podcast came to be
i ended up calling my daughter uh
jacqueline schultz who was an influencer
in her own right
really smart a teacher we used to sit
around for hours and that was my
if i could make her her and i would
laugh we'd make prank calls together
my wife would walk in and she'd hear all
this laughter and goes what is this for
and i go what do you mean what is this
for she goes well is it for a television
show
what do you read and i go no it's just
us she goes well then record it
um what's nice about i would think about
the podcast
is that you're doing something
uh useful with something that you'd be
doing anyway it sounds to me like
your whole life i mean i've been around
you the times you've done my show you're
doing pranks backstage
you once had a guy with you who was
bleeding from the ear and we kept
asking him is he okay and you say oh
don't worry about him
we thought he was having some kind of
brain hemorrhage
it turned out he's a friend of yours and
you guys were doing a prank on us
none of it was recorded this had nothing
to do with your appearance on the show
it was um it was just for your own
amusement so now
what's nice is you and your daughter are
saying let's capture some of that
and uh waste more people's time with it
i'm so sorry about that
it was funny it was funny it was funny
from new york you came to do the show in
l.a yeah well it's funny now i don't
think jeff
i don't think my producer was really
worried that someone
this friend of yours was having a brain
aneurysm and he was trying to convince
that person
he was thinking about calling an emt we
got to get this guy a brain scan and it
was youtube
ben affleck actually picked him up from
the floor so i brought in
he was supposed to be by he was acting
he was my agent or my pr guy
i'm doing conan and he had he had these
blood
pellets that come out of his ears and
his nose and he was bleeding and he
would be
on the floor bleeding but asking the
segment producer you know is howie
mandel going on
first my client and they go well you're
bleeding shouldn't we call somebody
he goes it's not about me can i go over
this segment with you yeah they're going
no
sir sir you believe you're bleeding
you're bleeding and then it was fun for
me
just to sit back and watch this chain of
events that they would go tell somebody
and you're you know five minutes away
from a huge broadcast
network show where you travel you're not
in your home studio like you don't have
enough
and i've got this idiot my friend idiot
lying on the floor
blood spewing out going can we go over
the segment one more time
you know i remember thinking that guy is
a great
agent because man you know that's
everyone's dream is an agent who would
be bleeding from both ears and still
be looking out for your interests and
not going to the hospital that's the
dream
you're a judge on of course on america's
got talent
i'm told that when simon cowell had his
accident recently
you kind of uh pranked him a little bit
with a gift is that the idea
i don't know if that was a prank i said
i sent him a bike
i sent him a bicycle you know he cuz he
got he got injured on an e-bike
he said he hit the the throttle on it it
threw him off he broke his back he's
he ended up six hours in six hours of
surgery
they implanted a rod in his back i want
to also say
that he's fine now you know he's on this
season
the guy is like the bionic man but i
know that he likes bikes and i know he
likes vehicles and i know he's not gonna
give it up so i sent him a
uh the safest bike i can so he can still
enjoy the outdoors and enjoy the speed
he has that need so what was he what was
the bike
it was a three-wheeler tricycle but if
he wants to go fast
you just you just pedal you just pedal
and you just
you know and he appreciated and that's a
good look isn't it yeah
he's got a uh lauren he's got a a lady
that he's with but i i don't think it's
the kind of bike you're going to
you should try and get him to ride it
and then tell him you're putting a
helmet on but put a baby bonnet on him
and just to see if you can get him
riding that down the street i would love
to see that
okay i'm gonna do that and i'll get you
the video it's you're an idea guy
conan and you've always been an idea
that's what i do you know
and that's what you just did that's what
i just did and we have proof
that i did it because it's on a zoom
that's being recorded
yes what do you let me ask you a
question are you going to be
more when this pandemic ends are you
going to be
more wary of germs do you think
than other people or do you think we're
all going to come to your level and
you're going to say the same
i'm hoping that i well i will stay the
same i don't think there is another
level
right neurosis or uh
that then i'm already at and i'm hoping
that people come to
like there is no reason to ever shake a
hand again are you looking forward to
shaking your head like you know what i
will say
i will say i'm a good handshaker i give
a firm grip
and i lean in and i look it right in the
eye i've got a good
strong man's handshake and so i'm gonna
lose that because i think that's the way
that i impressed people well everything
you said is not appealing to me first of
all it's firm you're holding it tight so
that
if there is something it's easily and
you know what i would do
i'd kind of pull leaning in i'd lean in
and i'd pull you in a little bit
and and i'd be like it's real good to
see you howie really good
then i'm not i don't want to ever meet
you again you know
i don't understand that i really don't
when you see somebody and even you see
somebody you know i think words are very
uh yeah they are enough really they
really are
unless you want to procreate or have
some
you know intimate fun there is no reason
for just an acquaintance to uh touching
lean in
touch exchange moistness
you know i don't think there's any
reason for that i'm going to miss
exchanging moistness with people
isn't that what happens though yes you
know i can say i'll be honest with you
for a minute serious with you for a
minute
i can shake hands and the reason i don't
shake hands is because i do have ocd and
i don't want to be triggered
if something happens but how many times
have you shaken
somebody's hand and then walked away
thinking
what what is that why is it wet
why how what you know it's the middle of
winter that's gotta be
i hope that's sweat and also we grew up
uh
you know learning to cover our mouth
yeah worst thing you can do
right but every time you sneeze or cough
i don't see people running off to the
sink to go wash their hands so this is
just a
cesspool we don't need to shake hands so
i wanna
we should do the what i like in some of
the far east countries i like the bow
oh i do the bow a lot i do the bow yeah
you do you do that i see you're doing
that on television yeah i've been doing
that for years and
and now when i see people i just do a
little quick bow and i think it's very
it's i honor you i honor your existence
i respect you
yeah i'm not touching you yeah i'm not
breathing and then i go in for the big
hug
i don't really do that if i hug i like i
like spooning and i like be
you know from behind good to see you no
i spoon i've spooned with you many times
it's nice it's very
we fit thank you you know i like the
curve of your back
let me make sure i get the word out
howie mandel does stuff
uh is available wherever you get your
podcast and this is you with your
daughter
and sounds like jacqueline schultz yes
jacqueline schultz it sounds like you're
having a subscribe
like please yes get out there and listen
um congratulations on all your uh
podcast success
you know i wanted to make your
podcasters well thank you i
always wanted to make it on my looks and
then the thing that's really worked for
me has been
a medium where i can't be seen um i
don't know what that means
i think the universe is telling me
something but uh
you know i can't wait what you can get
yeah you take what you can get
now you sound like my wife
i think everybody's wife anybody who has
a wife and
continues to have a wife at the end of
uh this
uh or through the the uh pandemic
rose of this pandemic i think we're all
hearing the same lines
yes we are and we all feel the same way
yes now's the time they should do that
show that they did on the network where
where they switched what was that called
somebody's wife went to live at somebody
else's house and somebody's husband
remember they always i didn't know
i mean i've gone to parties like that
but i didn't know that was a tv show
the key club there was there there is a
there's a tv show where you if somebody
else's wife moves in with somebody
else's family and they
i can't remember what it's called but
they should do that during covet
because it'd be more dangerous yes it
adds that element of danger
i like that see you're you're an idea
guy too howie
not only funny you could die
howie i'm going to end on that note uh
thank you very much for doing this
that is always a good closer that's the
way to get out it's the ultimate closer
all right buddy
i want you to be well and um i can't
wait to see you again with your friend
who pretends to have
a cerebral hemorrhage vic cohen i'll
give him a shout out all right buddy
thank you